herzlich willkommen bei clixoom ich
würde mal sagen high class denn jetzt
gibt es bei uns nur noch gäste vom
feinsten und der erste ist die comedy
herzlich willkommen bei pixum gerät
lieber teddy und bei uns immer die erste
frage kennst du ja alles klar
nee nee wie steht die uhr für ähnlich
was ich das sofa sprang wie ist die lage
katastrophal echt warum keine wohnung
mehr keine freundin mehr und kein auto
mehr gut aber das ist ja nicht so
schlimm oder katastrophen recht warum
weil ich jetzt nichts mehr ab christoph
aber das tolle ist ja wenn man in so
einer lebenssituation ist man zieht
dafür komiker raus oder so dies ja auch
guck mal da ihr habt mich jetzt zu hause
besucht in der garage wir holen hier
lebe ich okay ich meinen kader
ich dachte dass wir unsere tiefgarage
ist zu mir her ich habe müssen irgendwie
bleibe suchen ja ich gedacht gut die
tonne da kann ich mich umziehen
die tonne ist toll aber ich selber schon
geht es mir geht es gut die erde ist es
gut was machst du moment du hast ja das
ist ja du hast eine gigantische darf man
sagen youtube karriere hingelegt weil
mit der integrations umfrage millionen
views gemacht und direkt dann ab und
fernsehen nicht dass das stimmt nicht
ganz stimmt das nicht ganz noch nicht
immer so wenn man es so wenn man so
gesehen hat und dann und zweitens damals
nachliest überall steht youtube karriere
und dann entdeckt
ich hatte davor ist schon die idee fürs
fernsehen und ihr habt dann youtube
gemacht vielleicht einfach so rollen
ausprobieren wollte und so und dann hat
kurz bevor ich dann die täter bei zdfneo
gemacht aber bei diesem wettbewerb
mitgemacht habe kann denn diese dieser
integrationstest rein zufällig aber wenn
ich ein grund fürs zdf zu sagen
oder aber dieses thema und geben mussten
ja voten
das war ist ein grund also es hat das
voting wasser
diese halten ich glaube ohne die tat
auch ohne dem ipad das bestimmt auch
geschafft
wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich willst
dann bestimmt schon weil sie wissen so
sympathisch oder komisch mitleid dass
die leute gleich ok-mitglied geboten was
in afrika gibt es in afrika
der ist nicht da bin ich jetzt noch
hinterher musste am ohr bis schwarze
moderator wie hannah am ohr oder wie
heißt der breite ist sehr breit an
da gibts noch ein gemeinsamer der ist
auch nicht so naja egal aber alles kein
afrikaner dass du bist ja auch deutsche
oder afrikaner du bist geschichte ist ja
deine mutter ist vor also ungefähr knapp
nach seiner geburt mit sieben monaten
also sieben monate alt was ist sie aus
eritrea geflüchtet hier nach deutschland
das heißt von der geburt bis zu eritrea
aber eigentlich in deutschland
aufgewachsen und kannst alle dialekte
nein das stimmt nicht wieviel 12 30 14
15 16 24 25 67 20 37 38 40 41 40 so
ungefähr 44
fehlt nur noch ein unglaublich bis alle
kannst wie viele dialekte wie hat sie
drauf geschafft also baden württemberg
wisst ihr ja zur ausgebauten groß
geworden den den ersten quasi
mit der mutter mich auch nicht mit dem
mit der muttermilch habe ich bekommen
eine mischung aus action deutschen
probieren schwäbisch zurück
okay es war so eine mischung aus allem
so ein ausländer deutsch dass man hat
keine arbeit von seiner familie zum
beispiel kann man einen melder ein auto
wann hat man aber viel die hälfte das
habe ich mitbekommen und deutschland ich
in der schule gelernt ihre tricks dann
auch noch zu hause
da hast du denn noch kontakt in sein
heimatland oder ist das komplett
abgebrochen
wenn man flüchtet hat man dann quasi
alles gekappt oder was noch mal in
eritrea was für eine beziehung zu dem
land ist klickst du mir ist so was
ähnliches wie markus lanz ja ja bislang
hat ganz viel klicks um geguckt und dann
jeweils plötzliche cells über das immer
so das kann ernst sein das kann auch
lustig findet sich hier
es soll was ich oder ich möchte am
liebsten was über den menschen erfahren
wir haben noch kontakt
und was auch mal dort 96 und habe vor
nächstes jahr nochmal zu gehen habe ich
viel zu tun gehabt dass ich wohl dieses
jahr war letztes jahr nicht geschafft
aber nicht so sehr was ihm voll
was ist deine heimat deutschland
schwabenland mittlerweile auch köln und
und deswegen will ich auch zurück oder
nach eritrea um zu einem anderen teil
von mir kennen zu lernen
die nicht so gut kann dann werden wir
das kennst du nicht so gut oder wie
wirkt sich das aus dass du deine wurzeln
nicht so gut kennt wir haben ja schon
viel mitbekommt von herrn von unserer
mutter mir fröhlich und die sprache die
kultur ist die ganzen
zeremonien kaffeezeremonie das alles was
man so dass diese bruchteile von von der
kompletten kultur und ich will einfach
sehen was mit mir passiert wenn ich da
hingehe
da ist ein teil
fragen die die offen zum beispiel das
okay zu über bären löwen halt ob sie
wirklich gibt ja okay so sein können
dass es das ist was was du mir
beantworten die chancen stehen 1 99 1
aber einfach ich möchte einfach gucken
auf das was da was da so passiert aber
schon mal mit einem dokumentation
gesehen über ihre dreher und habe
gemerkt dass ich mich extremes verbunden
gefühlt haben richtig verbunden obwohl
ich das land ja nicht so gut ich bin
hier groß geworden ich war einmal dort
und sowieso zu dem afrikanischen
kontinent ich bin so grimmig ruft da ich
mit einer afrika reise machen kannst du
dir vorstellen dort zu leben also in
afrika ja also alle wenn ich mir älter
bin diese pendeln paar monate dort und
wieder zurück
also ich will hier in deutschland
bleiben aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
so mit meiner frau zusammen
hast du eine frau freundin 4 vj 44
mit welcher möchtest du dann nach
eritrea ist keiner
somit ist eine elektrische frau dort
haben möchte dort eine kauf kaufen und
deine frauen hier die dieses leben in
der gleichen stadt oder in verschiedenen
städten
das muss man trennen also dass sie halt
auch nicht was er hat jetzt gerade was
verraten wahrscheinlich was er nicht
verraten wollte und jetzt in
verschiedenen städten vier frauen hat er
ok und wie kommt die vier frauen damit
zurecht das oder kriegt sie das mit dass
du so verwurzelt ist in afrika aber
deutscher bist ja die vierte frau die
für frau ja ich glaube schon wenn nicht
dann muss jedes mal wenn ich mit dir
rede nickerchen machen okay also ich
glaube gibt es eigenschaften an dir die
für andere schwer nachvollziehbar sind
also was vielleicht afrikanisches keine
ahnung
das ist ja was ihre trainings
irgendetwas wo du sagst das versteht ist
wohl jemand außenstehenden gar nicht
verständlich warum ich so bin vielleicht
ein bisschen schnell eingeschnappt oder
neidisch das wäre eine deutsch
eingeschlafen oder du wirst sauer auch
er einen deutsche eigenschaft
ich glaube dass er immer so wenn man in
ein anderes land geht wo kulturen dass
er immer wenn man in dem land lebt und
leute kommen aus einem anderen land und
dann gibt es diese culture clash ist und
menschen erschrecken sich vor fremden
dingen die sie nicht kennen
das glaube ich schon auf jeden fall das
ist ja innerhalb mehr das ist innerhalb
der beziehung auch wenn du aus demselben
land kommt das ist ja schon so dass man
sich immer wieder das ding das man dem
gegenüber nicht versteht wenn man dann
die eltern und die geschwister oder die
freunde sieht man dann aber videos von
von von von früher oder so keine ahnung
und dann ist ja okay ich verstehe aber
gibt es bei dieser eigenschaft wo du
sagst das ist jetzt nicht deutsch
sondern dass es eindeutig ihre tricks
das habe ich irgendwie mit denen das
habe ich mit der muttermilch aufgesogen
ja ich glaube dieses dass man teilt ok
grundsätzlich dass man wenn man zusammen
ist dass man zusammen ist so das ganze
ganz normal bei uns da wird nicht da
sitzt keiner am tisch und ist alleine
das gibt's bei uns essen alle zusammen
und das ist glaube ich so oder dass man
was zu essen anbietet 500 mal
hintereinander willst das erste nein
danke er liegt also gar keine komme ich
mache etwas drobny dank so
angepasst
aber das ist schön für dich trotzdem
symbol hier in deutschland
wenn du jetzt de endlich entscheiden
müsste
was wäre dann klar deutschland ja ja ja
ich bin hier wie gesagt ich bin groß und
ich kenne ja nichts anderes aber ich
hab' ich besteht so eine gewisse
sehnsucht nach nach nach afrika es ist
ja auch ein irgendwie mystisches lahm ja
auf jeden fall ganz viel entspringt hat
begonnen er hat begonnen wiege der
menschheit viel hat apobank die luzie
ist daraus der ecke welche luzie der
erste mensch also okay jaja meine auf
jeden fall ich bin hier das ist meine
heimat ich bin groß geworden und ich
liebe deutschland extrem und ich weiß
auch dass es nicht selbstverständlich
ist dass wir so gut leben wie wir leben
in deutschland gut das sind dass wir uns
über nicht sorgen müssen zum thema geben
ja es geht es richtig gut hast du dir
schon mal darüber gedanken mache dann
mache ich mehr oft lange das ist
unglaublich das ist so deswegen also ich
bin ich probiere jeden ich sagte mir
wirklich fast jeden tag gedacht haben
wohl viele arbeiten ist vergessen warum
geben fast jeden tag so dankbar sein mit
mit wirklich kleinigkeiten ich hab mir
wo ich komme nach hause ich kann mir das
ds zu machen
ich kann mich waffen ich komm ich kann
machen was ich dinge die für uns
selbstverständlich erscheint sind den
anderen ländern da musst du keine ahnung
hast du richtig glück haben um so leben
zu können oder irgendwelchen längstens
oder geld einfach nur deswegen
ich bin glücklich hier wie ist es bei
dir wie bist du auf comedy gekommen wer
hat das bei der entdeckt hast du selber
entdeckt da die brüder du bist ja mit
deinen geschwistern nach köln nicht
rausrückt hast du zwei brüder älteren
bruder mit den bis nach köln auf
die waren schon früher genauso bis denn
hinterher also die waren schon früher
hier und aber kommen die habe ich schon
meine mutter schon als klein war meine
hunde zum lachen okay ich war wie du
dich gerade beschrieben was ich war
früher auch schon immer einfach so
generell glücklich und ich mag nach wie
vor immer menschen ich mag es gerne auf
menschen zu dem menschen mich zu
unterhalten so ich ja ich mag einfach
menschen so und ich liebe es wenn
menschen lachen wenn ich wenn ich jemand
traurig gesehen habe dann hab ich immer
das bedürfnis ihnen wieder zum lachen zu
bringen aufzupäppeln soll deswegen ist
schon ganz früh und ich habe früher
schon so dinge imitiert im fernsehen
oder meinen freunden dinge vorgespielt
gemacht und wann es zum beruf geworden
als ich als ich sechzehn oder siebzehn
war habe ich mich entschlossen auf die
bühne zu gehen
so habe aber alles um mich herum schon
auf der straße immer zu wenig gemacht
wenn ich irgendwann der reihe irgendwo
in der schlange stand oder so hat dann
so okay jetzt probiere ich mal das aus
oder haben einfach auftritte abgecheckt
dann hat das sofort erblickt
so habe ich mir das aufgebaut und
irgendwann habe ich mich entschlossen
habe dann angefangen zu moderieren bei
festivals und dann habe ich eine
schauspiel ausbildung gemacht irgendwann
mal und dann kam innerhalb nach köln
gezogen dann gemüse können da kann alles
so nach und nach diversen
fernsehproduktionen mitgespielt musical
hairspray hier in köln musste gar nicht
singen oder dass man gespräche
ein bisschen klingt
ok so könnte man dran arbeiten
findest du ja ein bisschen tätig ich
glaube du kannst besser sind als es
reicht zum überleben ich will nicht
sagen dass musiker also musiker die
haben popsänger das hat gereicht da das
wasser was wie stellst du hast jetzt
eben riesen youtube erfolg gehabt du
hast eben in den film mitgespielt
musical gemacht theater glaube ich auch
ne also eigentlich alles gemacht wie
stellst oder was die welt für dich der
traumjob
also ich wünsche mir dass ich in filmen
in großen produktionen auch wirklich
einen schönen rollen spielen darf
aber so den traumjob traumjob habe ich
kann ich mich einfach ich wünsche mir
dass ich das machen kann was was ich
dass ich gerade mache ich mit meiner
tour zu spielen
eine show zu machen dass ich meine
videos macht und so und ich glaube dass
leute zum lachen zu bringen
ich habe unbedingt das erreichen habe
ich gar nicht glück nicht so wie es
gerade ist und wenn
sich noch andere türen öffnen ist cool
und wenn nicht wird sich irgendwas wird
etwas anderes ergeben und es wird schon
einen grund haben warum das ist aber ich
bin da echt ich bin zufrieden und
glücklich mit dem was ich mache hat auch
glück gehabt kann man sagen oder weil
das glück oder wann das war sich lange
harte arbeit
der eine sagt ich habe nicht ewig
gedauert bis ich endlich mein durchbruch
handeln das vergessen viele dass vor
bevor irgendwie so ein hype beginnt das
da schon jahrelang das forschen dinge
passiert sind ja bei mir ich habe auch
ich da ich habe die schauspieler durch
keiten die sieben-tage-woche ich habe
nicht viel kontakt zu meinem freund
gehabt nur darauf konzentrieren als ich
hierher gezogen bin habe ich habe ich
gearbeitet die ganze zeit habe
irgendwelche jobs gemacht gekellnert
überall war nicht versichert sich sodann
hatte keine kohle aber ich habe alles
glücklich gemacht überhaupt nicht so
dass ich sage ich habe alles so ich
wüsste für was ich mache und ich glaube
also es ist also du musst dich dafür
entscheiden und du musst hart arbeiten
aber du musst problem munter zu bleiben
und ich in schweren zeiten nicht
irgendwie dich aufzugeben und dann
glaube ich auch also ich glaub dass du
zeichen bekommst du dass du geführt wird
wenn es zulässt deswegen einfach
entspannt so wird nicht so entspannt und
so ist leben geht nicht nur es geht
nicht nur darum dass wir hier vor der
kamera stehen die geilsten so wenn man
sie das bewusst macht dann dann ist es
leben nicht ganz klar
es ist so ein bisschen ist es ein
bisschen so dem flow folgen also was war
auf jeden fall auf jeden fall erstmal
entspannen
okay du bist sie entspannen ja und dann
einfach mal ja schön ja wieso hat er
recht der absolut und aus der
entspannung entstehen die schönsten
sachen da wächst was schön und spontan
und ist es nicht verkopft ist es ehrlich
es passiert einfach
und dieses passiert müssen wir sowieso
glaube ich in deutschland da wir sowieso
viel nachdenken zu verkopft sehr müssen
wir wieder lernen so einfach
krone ist sagen die leute ja ich wäre
natur ist und ehrlich jetzt ja bei mir
sagen hat irgendwas anderes genommen
also okay aber einfach entspannen
zufrieden sein mit dem was man nicht
unbedingt und weil ich ich muss
unbedingt lassen dass das erreichen
einfach ein bisschen zu entspannen
ja um sich umgucken sein dass er voll
geil man man man hätte es nach drei
jahren immer noch fett
ich hab meine freunde sind immer noch da
wir können zusammen kochen dass die
ganzen einfach sein muss
ich hab's ja auch nicht immer was dann
geschah wobei ist es hat auch mit anlage
was du sagst ja du hast das schon als
kind gehabt manche leute können das
nicht die können es nicht
die machen sich die sorgen die denken an
viele haben auch sie sagen das leben ist
schwer
und wenn wenn wir an all das denken
würden was das leben schwer macht
übernommen
ja das ist wie gesagt man muss man muss
ja man muss sich bewusst machen
hier macht mir dass er auch mal ist es
nicht so dass ich jeden tag entspannt
durchs leben gehen aber ich sag mir
jeden tag dass sich dass es nicht
selbstverständlich sollte sich glücklich
sein darf es ist alles schön die geht's
gut ich sag mir geht's gut sehr
glücklich habe keine angst vor wasser in
existenzängste warum warum film zu
beweisen und hass sowieso nicht in der
hand riss du weißt nie was morgen
passiert deswegen genießt den tag beste
genießt und sehr gut zu den menschen die
dir begegnen sei besser ehrlich so
einfache sache zu respektvoll und hayden
nicht unser einfach lachen wird sagen
haben spaß zusammen
super super einstellungen kann ich nur
unterschreiben
vielen dank gerne darauf jetzt
entspannen muss man ganz gut jetzt alle
leute entspannen